if you're looking to become the go-to
expert in your field then this video is
for you what's that believe nation it's
Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe in the amazing
talent that you have inside here that I
want to see explode out onto the world
one of the questions I get asked a lot
by entrepreneurs is I'm an expert I want
to be seen as the expert I want to be
the person that people go to for my
niche my industry my area of expertise
how do I do it and so in this video I'm
gonna share my seven ways on how to be
the go-to expert in your field way
number one is actually be an expert and
that's not a joke a lot of people who
think they know a lot about an industry
are not actually that great at what they
do
and so you need to put in the work to be
the actual expert in your field if you
are not the expert that's okay you can
document your journey along the way to
becoming one a great example I can think
of is a guy named Michael Dunlop he had
a series that he had on his website for
a while where he was documenting how to
be a successful internet marketer and he
didn't know a lot himself he had done
some things but he wasn't the expert he
had all these people on it was doing
interviews with them and I loved
watching his stuff because I wanted to
learn how to be a better internet
marketer myself as he started learning
from all these successful people he
built up his credibility he built up his
knowledge base and then soon he got to
be an expert in the field too he learned
enough from all these other people he
started applying their knowledge he
started tweaking it and adapting it to
his own template his own personality his
own style and he started learning things
on his own but then he could teach as
well and so if you are the expert that's
great if you're not don't pretend to be
but you can document your journey and
bring on other experts learn from them
it's a great hack like if you ever want
to learn how to do something interview
somebody who knows what they're doing
and showcase them on your channel on
your platform even if it's small you'd
be surprised at how many people say yes
and in the path of documenting your
journey you then become the expert
[Music]
way number two is picked your niche if
you're in a giant industry it can be
hard to be the go-to person and so the
way to start is to pick your niche go
smaller and then expand your base so as
an example I love baseball so we'll use
the Toronto Blue Jays as an example
maybe you are the expert on the Toronto
Blue Jays minor-league system right how
many people really know the ins and outs
of the Toronto Blue Jays minor-league
system you could be that person it
wouldn't be that hard to develop the
skills to be that person then as you got
that under your hood you are the expert
you can expand and you could be the
person who knows the Toronto Blue Jays
everything trying to Blue Jays and then
after that you could expand and be the
person who knows baseball and you just
keep building your knowledge set and
your base and your expertise you started
here you started one niche and as you
got better you explained it I think
about Facebook that's how they started
they started just being for college
campuses that's all that was for college
campuses and then as college students
started to use it they told other people
and they brought on their grandparents
and their parents and their friends and
their kids and it just started to expand
we're now Facebook is for everyone and
so if you start to broad at the
beginning then it's hard to be seen as
that expert because you're not
specialized enough there's lots of
competition there's lots of people who
do it where if you can pick a niche be
known as that person for this specific
niche you get paid more you get lots of
attention for it's easier to stand out
it's easier to be the go-to expert and
then you slowly build out your skill
sets and what you're known for
[Music]
we number three is form alliances I've
been looking at who are the people in
your industry who have a similar target
audience and how can you start working
with them to showcase your expertise and
get some recognition and credibility in
my case as an example when I was trying
to learn about YouTube when trying to
grow I follow Tim Schmoyer and Darrell
use on YouTube these were the go-to guys
for me of how to build a YouTube channel
and I was in their community I had a
previous background in entrepreneurship
in venture capital and building
businesses and speaking and so as I got
more comfortable with their content I
knew what they were looking for I
reached out to them and what I did was
pitch them different ideas that I knew
would be good content for their channel
because I was a part of their community
and Tim I was on three or four times and
that was part of his series there I was
on once or twice and that started
getting me even more credibility at the
time both of their channels were bigger
than mine I found a way to add value
based off my expertise that helped build
up my exposure everybody who watched
their content now knew a little bit
about me who was the seventh carmical
guy oh that's the thing you said was
pretty interesting I'm gonna go check
him out
they come and they subscribe to my
channel and so looking at who you can do
collaborations with inside the industry
who is not a direct competitor of yours
but has some complimentary ideas but
still serves the same customers it can
be really really important to building
up your credibility and getting your
name more well-known
[Music]
we number four is create content what I
would suggest is figure out what is the
best execution of sharing your content
what do you love doing for me I love
video this is where I like to be I like
YouTube I like the idea that my content
lists forever
I don't like platforms as much where my
stuff disappears in 24 hours I want my
grandkids to see this video and every
video that I make that's always the
intention I'm trying to build a legacy
here and so YouTube really fits well for
my skill set and where my audience is if
you want to be known as a go-to expert
in your industry then you want to think
about where are your customers paying
attention it's marketing 101 where are
your customers and then you want to be
there and then you combine it with what
your skills are now with social media
your customers are on a lot of different
platforms but if you're selling b2b
you're gonna go to LinkedIn and if you
love making video and your customers
there you're gonna go to youtube if you
love writing and your customers are
there you might still go LinkedIn but
you might do medium or you might do
Twitter if you can keep it short and
concise and so figuring out what the
best execution of your idea spreading is
is where you want to be you don't need
to be everywhere so she at the start I
think that's terrible advice and say go
everywhere because you will suck at
everything and you don't stand out in
any of them where it's better to be
amazing at one thing and then be able to
expand beyond so pick where your
audience are and pick what you love
doing and share your message because as
long as you just keep your ideas in here
and nobody knows about it you might be
the greatest expert in the world but
nobody will find you because you're not
sharing enough it's also never been
easier to be the go-to expert if you
actually know what you're talking about
because the proliferation of ideas has
never been easier to do then right now
then right now if you watching this
video it's never been easier to spread
ideas just make sure that you have the
right ideas to spread and use the right
platform to fit your personality
[Music]
we're number five is used traditional
media there's still a lot of benefit in
using traditional media not as much as
before but still being able to put New
York Times or CNN or ink magazine up on
your website adds a lot of credibility
so when somebody is visiting your site
and they see that you've done these
things you've been in these newspapers
you've been on magazines maybe not the
cover but you've been in a magazine
you've been recognized as an expert then
it adds more credibility and then people
will talk about you and want to come
back I want to refer you the very first
one that I got with a major publication
was New York Times I was I want to say
19 or 20 years old and I forget what the
topic was even about I think it was
something around work-life balance or
something like that it didn't even
matter like it doesn't matter what the
story is it's that I wasn't in New York
Times write and I put that on my website
and people said oh he's in the New York
Times he's done he's done something and
so then that led to interviews here and
here and here and here and so that could
expand my base and if they see you as
being an expert in one field then it's
easy to transition to others and other
publications want to write about you and
you slowly become known as the person
I'd also be looking at any of those
lists that come out of the top X
speakers or industry experts Inc
magazine does them in Forbes Azzam and
fortune does them find out who the
person is who's writing those lists and
connect with them and let them know what
you're all about and maybe you'll be
considered for the next one I've never
done that purposely in terms of outreach
I've been featured on ink magazine and a
couple other ones as top leadership
speakers and top social media experts
and all these things that just
everything adds more credibility I've
never forced it I've never tried to make
an attempt to be put on these lists but
you could it's not that hard you just
have to get to know the person who's
making that list follow them social
media engage with them let them know
what you're up to support them and the
campaign's that they're putting out
comment on their content give them
suggestions and feedback producing you
get to be known as an expert and then
you're going to be featured on the next
list which will give you even more
credibility
[Music]
way number six is tell your story this
is how you stand out this is how people
get to know you and remember you what is
your story what are you so great at what
is your history how did you get here
from where you were I think a lot of
people still come off as super boring
super conventional super conservative
and you have a boring picture and a
boring bio and I can't make a connection
if I don't understand who you are and
what you staying for it's harder for me
to want to work with you to want to hire
you to want to pay you to come speak at
my event and to help spread the message
and so having an authentic picture
ideally a video where you can really
share your story and get into it you
don't have to be unless you're a speaker
you don't have to have a great video and
if you are speaking you need a great
video we're where is your video if
you're a speaker but if you're not just
telling your story like if you love
making shoes you don't have to be the
best person on video but let me just
feel your passion for shoes you can be
the go-to expert on all things shoes and
if I see a video with care and love and
heart and you tell me the story of how
you got into the shoe business and why
it means so much to you that's gonna win
me over that's gonna make me want to do
business with you and talk about you and
write about you and hire you and work
with you and refer people to you you
need to tell your story that's how you
win as an entrepreneur when people
connect with you personally and not just
a corporate building that you're trying
to create
[Music]
and we number seven is over-deliver like
crazy if you truly are an expert than
your goal is in every single
conversation with somebody you are
blowing their mind with the amount of
value and content that you can provide
this is always my goal in every meeting
with an entrepreneur I'm trying to blow
their mind to help them not not from a
egotistical point of view or even III
really need to be the expert and so I'm
gonna blow them away I just feel it's
the right thing to do like I want
somebody to make a change if you come to
me and you have a limiting belief or you
have a problem and I know that I can
help you if I can't then that's a
different issue but I know that I can
help you I want you to make that change
and I will be on you and I will raise
the stakes and I will get you inspired
so that you can actually go off and do
that thing and what ends up happening is
if you go off and do the work then
you're gonna tell your friends about me
and you're gonna subscribe to my YouTube
channel you're gonna consume more
content again it's not a strategic thing
but it could be I do it because it's
just the right thing to do and I love it
but you could do it with strategy behind
it and that every conversation you have
every email you're sending out every
social media engagement that you create
every speaking a gig that you get every
fan that you're talking to every
customer that comes in prospect or not
you blow them away
you give them insane value and if you're
over delivering like crazy that's when
word of mouth starts to spread and
that's what you need as an entrepreneur
listen you need an expert you're not
taking out Super Bowl commercials you
need people to talk about you and that
comes from understanding your story
understanding your mission understanding
how good you are what you're doing but
giving them insane value if you do that
then we will spread so those are my
seven ways on how to be the go-to expert
in your field I would love to know which
of the seven ways have the biggest
impact on you and what you're going to
apply in your business somehow
did I miss an eight nine ten that you
want to add to the list leave in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out now I made this video because
wills gills asked me to so if there's a
topic you'd like me to cover in a future
video check out the request line in the
description and go cast your vote I just
might do it finally you want to give a
quick shout out to john sonmez is a
simple programmer thank you so much John
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word featured on your YouTube
channel I really appreciate all the
support man Congrats on all the success
you've had on your channel and
so excited to see it continue to grow so
thank you guys again for all the love I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever here
when where it is
much love I'll see you soon if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details